joe biden is banning seven countries
worth of africans from entering the
country as the new omicron variant of
kovid rages across the continent
the president has cut off travel from
south africa botswana zimbabwe namibia
lizoto ezwatini
that's actually what i had for dinner
last night mozambique in malawi which
might remind some people who can
remember all the way back to last year
of donald trump's travel ban which joe
biden called quote hysterical xenophobia
here is how white house press secretary
jen saki tried to explain away the
change of tune
before joe biden was president he said
that cloven travel restrictions on
foreign countries were hysterical
xenophobia and fear-mongering so what
changed
well i would say first to put it in full
context peter what the president was
critical of was the way that the former
president put out i believe a xenophobic
tweet uh and how he called that what he
called the cocuronavirus uh and and who
he directed it at the president has not
been critical of
travel restrictions we have put those in
place ourselves we put them in place
ourselves in the spring but no he does
not believe he believes we should follow
the advice of health and medical experts
that's exactly what he did and putting
in place these restrictions over the
weekend
ah okay you see it wasn't what trump did
but how he did it
the white house is now resorting to the
retort your wife makes after a pointless
argument it's not what you said it's how
you said it
pretty weak sauce for a simple case of
hypocrisy that stretches all the way
from south africa to waukesha wisconsin
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from the drummer's
workshop at norm's music
who says
santa's eggnog probably had some
fluoride in it
this in response to i would imagine the
norway norwegian gay santa claus ad
so biden bans africans because of the
omicron just one more variant just a few
more days to slow the spread we're now
we're now at 20 months of 15 days to
slow the spread but just a little bit
more
and then don't worry you can get back to
your normal life people obviously are
looking at the hypocrisy they're looking
at what seem to be these pointless
lockdowns this unnecessary up ending of
our way of life and they're saying cut
it out we don't want this anymore we
don't want the lockdowns we don't want
the masks we don't want the mandatory
fauciachi we don't want you we don't
want you ruling class that's why
your approval ratings are all
in the doldrums right now
dr fauci has a different explanation the
the exalted doctor the highest paid
government employee in the federal
government and the uh the most powerful
politician in the country
who has survived seven u.s presidents at
this point dr fauci says the reason
people are going after him is not
because he keeps changing his mind and
it's not because he's lied and it's not
because he's
held on to his power for well over 15
days now well you know coming up on two
years
it's because
he represents
science
there are a lot of republican senators
uh taking aim
at this i mean that's okay i'm just
gonna do my job
and i'm gonna be saving lives and
they're going to be lying
it seems another layer of danger to play
politics around matters of life and
death right exactly exactly and to me
that's
that's unbelievably bad
because all i want to do is save
people's lives and i mean
anybody who's looking at this carefully
realizes that there's a distinct
anti-science
flavor to this
so if they get up and criticize science
nobody's going to know what they're
talking about
but if they get up and really aim their
bullets at tony fauci well people can
recognize there's a person there so it's
easy to criticize but they're really
criticizing science
because i represent science
that's dangerous to me that's more
dangerous
than the slings and the arrows that get
thrown at me
that is dangerous dr faji it is very
dangerous when some flunky bureaucrat
liar
claims to be the vicar of science on
earth to represent to stand in for
science
itself
i gave a speech you know i hate to say i
told you so i gave a speech probably a
year ago now if not
if not longer ago
where i said that dr fauci considers
himself the high pontiff and the priest
of progressivism instead of wearing a
cassock he wears a lab coat instead of a
pectoral cross like a bishop or the pope
he wears a stethoscope but that he
considers himself to be the ultimate
authority in our government and very
possibly on earth and
seems i was right he is using language
here that is a bastardization of the
language that
a pope might use a pope who can who will
claim based on apostolic succession
based on the institution of the
church on earth by christ himself that
he
is the supreme pontiff the vicar
of our lord
dr fauci
who i suspect would mock those sorts of
claims his religious views
don't seem exactly orthodox
dr fauci is making even more audacious
claims with regard to his role
in science
i am
i represent science
and i'm look i'm just trying to save
people's lives i'm going to save
people's lives and those republican
senators are going to lie
the arrogance
far
far more delusional far more arrogant
than anything any right-wing religious
person has ever said
and
you you saw at the end he laughs he goes
who cares what those senators say they
want me out of my job those duly elected
representatives of the people
whatever who cares what they say i'm
just going to keep doing my job and the
laughing is warranted because he is more
powerful than the senators
in the constitutional system that the
framers and the founders envisioned
probably dr fauci would not be more
powerful than u.s senators but in
reality he is
senators are going to come and go dr
fauci is going to remain presidents are
going to come and go dr fauci is going
to remain
they can do their damnedest to to get
him out of office it's not going to do
anything
these public health officials are
unhinged
some apparently
even less hinged than dr fauci the
canadian indigenous health expert
employed by the
canadian government
has just lost her job
after being exposed for lying about her
native american ancestry for her whole
career
so
uh this woman
she became the nation's top voice
on indigenous
native health
and now she's been kicked out of her
government job and her university
professorship because
she lied about it she initially said
that she was a member i think of the
metis tribe and then she said that she
was also anishinabe
and tlingit and her story kept changing
and she kept becoming even more and more
native and then she would wear native
clothing and and then it turned out that
she's just a regular white lady
so
so she took a job from a native american
presumably that job would have gone to a
native american in our identity politics
culture
and uh and she claimed to be native
american for her whole career and then
she was exposed much like elizabeth
warren who did exactly the same thing
and uh and a number of other people too
rachel dallas all did this for black
people and there have been others
there's an nyu professor i believe who
who was a what white lady jewish lady
pretended to be black
the reason i bring this up is not just
to make fun of these lunatic women like
the canadian doctor and elizabeth warren
and all the rest of them
the reason i bring it up
is because we are told that some races
are oppressed and some races are
privileged
and we're told that basically white
people are privileged and everyone else
is what else is oppressed and especially
native americans and indigenous people
they're the most depressed of all
but
the reality seems to be the opposite
because the white people
are pretending to be native american
if being native american meant that you
were oppressed if being white meant that
you were privileged by the law even by
society today just standards and mores
then it would go in the other direction
native people would pretend to be white
white people everyone would pretend to
be white because that's how you get the
privilege
and people want privilege don't they
or they want to be able to claim
victimhood when actually victimhood
confers a certain privilege it confers
social currency
gets back to something we've been
talking about for a number of days now
which is that
when when you scapegoat somebody when
you say straight white men are the cause
of every problem in the world
you are scapegoating but you don't know
that you're scapegoating the people who
are doing this the libs actually think
they're just on the side of justice
they're on the side of the oppressed
they're on the side of the victims
but they're not they're not
and i think that you see
more proof of this every single day but
as long as kooky white ladies put on
headdresses and and frizz their hair to
make them look more african as long as
that is a social phenomenon
then our sense of who is oppressed and
who is privileged is backwards and
that's just the way it goes and you see
this not just in some
looney tunes from the canadian health
ministry you're seeing this all the way
up to
the white house
all right which is which has a lot of
problems these days not not the least of
which is the economy so when you want to
take advantage of the current economic
situation i would recommend you check
out
american financing there is still time
to make a positive impact on your budget
before year end as mortgage rates remain
near money-saving lows now you might be
thinking
why
my mortgage it's fine as it is
well maybe you should be asking how can
my mortgage work for me and that answer
can be found in american financing
america's home for home loans because
they give sound advice they don't
pressure you instead their salary based
mortgage consultants get to know you
so they can lead you to greater overall
savings could be as simple as finding a
shorter loan term or consolidating debt
because there is more to a refinance
than just a lower rate
and through this they save customers up
to a thousand dollars a month
so why don't you see what they can do
for you call 800-685-5600
that is
800-685-5696 or you can visit
americanfinancing.net nmls
1-82334-mlsconsumeraccess.org
[Music]
joe biden
is not going to visit the families of
the victims of the waukesha terrorist
attack where a black nationalist guy
intentionally drove his suv
into a bunch of i guess mostly white
people and and injured dozens of them
and killed half a dozen of them
uh joe biden's not going to go visit
those families he's barely going to
acknowledge it peter ducey in the white
house briefing room asked jen sock he
said hey jen
why isn't the president going to
acknowledge or go spend some time with
the victims of this
terrible
attack in wisconsin here's her answer
since the president said that this
administration is monitoring the
situation in waukesha closely it has
been revealed by prosecutors that the
assailant the assailant swerved his
truck side to side as part of an
intentional act to run over as many
people as possible six people are dead
some children remain hospitalized why
hasn't the president visited the members
of this christmas parade attack
well i would say first as you saw the
president convey last week our hearts go
out to this community to the people in
waukesha that we've been in touch
obviously with officials there and we're
all watching as people are recovering
and this is such a difficult time of
year for for this to happen it's
difficult any time
obviously any president going to visit a
community requires a lot of assets
requires taking their resources and
it's not something that i have a
previewed at this point point in time
but we remain in touch with local
officials and certainly our our hearts
are with the community as they've gone
through such a difficult time takes a
lot of resources for him to get out
there and so it's just not a good idea
you know it's just but you know we're
monitoring it so so he but he can't go
in person that would be crazy
you know he went to george floyd's
funeral
he went and you might say well he wasn't
president then but he was
running for president he was
going to be the nominee
this was in june of 2020 it was
allegedly the height of the coronavirus
pandemic when ordinary americans were
not allowed to even hold funerals for
their dead loved ones and george floyd
got a special exemption from this
because he became a secular saint
so so canonized by the media and then
joe biden showed up there and he even
spoke at the funeral
he was he was
running for president was going to
become the president he was a former
vice president he was a former senator
of many decades so it wasn't
logistically it wasn't tough to do that
for george floyd
but it's it's too difficult for joe
biden now to go visit the families of
not just
the family of a career criminal who was
killed while committing a crime and
resisting arrest under circumstances
that will be debated for many years to
come
no no
he can't go visit the families of the
six dead people
one of the victims was a child
and the dozens of other people who were
injured killed in a terror attack by a
black nationalist can't go visit them or
it's too logistically it's no it's not
it's not but it does get back to this
point of
oppression and privilege
because the the left's narrative is that
white people are bad and black people
are good and all black people are good
and all white people are bad and
the greatest scourge the most pervasive
evil in the country is white supremacy
and so the george floyd
event the george floyd killing
did
really didn't even didn't fit that
narrative but they made it fit that
narrative george floyd became this
innocent guy who was doing absolutely
nothing wrong and the officer became a
vicious white supremacist even though
there was really no evidence of that and
so it fit that narrative whereas what
happened in waukesha doesn't fit that
narrative because the guy there just
looking at his social media appears to
hate white people he espouses black
nationalist rhetoric hebrew israelite
rhetoric that's the kooky group that
believes that black people are real jews
and the jews are evil
and according to the evidence that we
have he was swerving to hit people with
his car he wasn't trying to avoid them
he's actually gunning to hit people
so that narrative doesn't fit and so
he's not going to show up
and and a lot of politicians don't want
to
talk about it be because the minute that
that you suggest that the left's
narrative on race or sex or whatever
isn't correct you're accused of being a
bigot or a racist or a phobe or whatever
stupid word they're going to call you
and so a lot of politicians even
republicans don't want to touch it they
say better just to sit back here and
let's just move on and let's just ignore
it one politician who's not just going
to ignore it
florida governor ron desantis
is that how it works the suvs they just
drive by themselves this just kind of
happened and they say oh this was a big
accident you never actually hear the
discussion about who committed this
what was the motivation
this guy was a career criminal led out
on didn't really have any bail basically
should not have even been on the street
uh had clear
anti-white animus uh and this was an
intentional act and it seems like you
know for corporate press they're more
apt to characterize a parent who goes to
a school board meeting to protest bad
policies as a domestic terrorist than
somebody who intentionally rams an suv
into a crowd of innocent people and
we'll see what the actual motivation was
uh it very well may have been in
response to what happened with kyle
rittenhouse and you have to wonder if
that's the case
almost surely this guy's view of written
house was was colored by all these media
lies
this
press conference
was
basically perfect
it was written if you had
the most sophisticated
hollywood
washington dc
writer to hit every single point you
need to hit
he probably couldn't have done a better
job than what you just saw there in that
press conference
desantis is
getting the attack for what it was
he's demonstrating the courage to talk
about it to talk about crime first of
all
a lot of republicans now are running
away from talking about crime they want
to talk about criminal justice reform
and letting the criminals out of prison
up to and including donald trump who did
that i love donald trump but but even he
made a big legislative effort to let
criminals out of prison desantis is
saying no we need to put more criminals
in prison should never have been out in
the first place he's demonstrating the
courage to talk about the left's crazy
racial narratives he's saying look this
is an anti-white crime by all evidence
that we've got
we always talk about anti-black
ness in in our culture but we never talk
about anti-white discrimination and
bigotry and he's willing to talk about
that so again that's you're not supposed
to touch that that's not what the
establishment wants you to talk about
desantis is willing to do it and then
most important of all beyond the crime
and beyond the left's kooky racial
narratives
he's he's putting it all in the media
he's saying we'll find out what the
motivation was here but if the
motivation was
something to do with kenosha and kyle
rittenhouse
then the media bears some culpability
here because the media
presented a narrative to unhinged freaks
like this guy in waukesha
who
who probably believed the narrative that
kyle rittenhouse was a terrible white
supremacist and this was a racial attack
and it was just bs from the media
but
but freaks like the guy in in waukesha
aren't going to know that
and sometimes and so what what desantis
is saying is
this is
this crime
lives within a context of media
corruption
he opens up talking about the corporate
media closes talking about the corporate
media
really smart the other thing that
desantis does here that's really clever
is injects himself into the story why is
the governor of florida
talking about a crime that took place in
wisconsin
why
who how does he do that i get why he
would talk about coronavirus and he's
been kind of the leading voice among
governors on coronavirus
but how is he going to inject himself
into this story in wisconsin well he's
holding a press conference about how
florida supports law enforcement
right so that's something that a
governor can do we support law
enforcement it's obviously an
opportunity it was bait for the media to
show up and then he can smack the media
down on this story in wisconsin because
it would seem clear to me that governor
desantis
is eyeing the presidency
it's very clever stuff he's he's
right on the issue but he's also playing
a pretty clever game
in terms of setting himself up to run
for president now if donald trump runs
for president again probably that's
dead on arrival
probably he clears the field but if not
he's positioning himself pretty well for
a guy who was relatively unknown
a couple of years ago
now speaking of the media
speaking of the presidency the the libs
who run almost the entire media they
know that joe biden is not looking so
hot
they know that
he's his mental acuity not what it once
was and it was never all that great
uh they know that physically he's not
doing well his physician just said that
he has trouble walking and that sort of
thing they know his approval rating is
down in the 30s
then they look at kamala harris
her approval rating is down in the 20s
her approval rating as vice president is
lower than dick cheney's was
by the end of his tenure looking over
the iraq war and after he shot that guy
in the face so that's not looking great
so do you know
who the desperate media are trying to
generate buzz for presidential buzz for
2024
this is really really pathetic
they're trying to make
president pete bootage happen
now i don't know if they must have
blinders on or something maybe they're
just getting too much blue light in
their eyes which is why they really
ought to check out blue blocks one of
the worst parts about staring at a
screen all day is that usually you get a
ton of blue light in your eyes and you
don't even really notice it you don't
notice it until you block out the blue
light and then your eyes feel a little
less strained and it can it can help
with anxiety and headaches and all that
sort of stuff this is why i love
the blue blocks blue light computer
glasses
other brands do not compare to the
quality you get from blue blocks glasses
blue blocks are made in optics
laboratories in australia they are not
mass produced in factories in asia and
unlike other blue light glass companies
blue blocks uses science-backed
technology tested to ensure that they
work these classes come in
non-prescription prescription and
reading options blue blocks also has
great products such as the low blue
light bulbs red light therapy devices
and 100 blackout sleep masks all backed
by
science blue blocks ship worldwide in
rapid time they have easy returns and
exchanges
trust me you're going to love it when
you block out that blue light blue
blocks currently has their black friday
sale campaign running great news for all
of you as you can save 25 off all
products through the end of the day
today the 30th of november 2021.
i definitely recommend ordering more
products during this mega sale this is
right now it's i know we're going an
extra day but go check it out
blueblox.com to save 25
blueblocks.com blublox.com
25 discount code is automatically
applied at checkout also make sure you
go get an incredible book i'm not just
talking about my books you all know
about reasons to vote for democrats a
comprehensive guide that was my number
one amazon best-selling blank book still
selling like hot cakes years later makes
a great stocking stuffer you know about
speechless controlling words controlling
mine's my number one national
best-selling a book that just came out
this year that one has words in it so i
appreciate that
this is a totally different genre of
book
it's from my colleague matt walsh it's a
children's book
and it's called johnny the walrus
johnny the walrus is an excellent tale
of identity and imagination it's waiting
for you to purchase it on amazon right
now head over to johnny the walrus
j-o-h-n-n-y
thewalrus.com
pick up a copy of matt walsh's timely
masterpiece i have been waiting for this
book to come out for a long time i read
the draft of it when matt wrote it up
it's uh
it's about a little boy who thinks he's
a walrus and unfortunately his crazy
mother in crazy society
indulge him in that uh in that delusion
go check out the book today we'll be
right back with a lot more
welcome back
to the show
the libs are trying to make president
pete happen
and i assume none of you read
these beltway liberal establishment
outlets like the hill
or politico or any that's usually
sensible conservative folk who don't
work in politics professionally they
don't ever even i mean i barely look at
them and i do work in politics
professionally but they're really trying
to make pete happen
so the hill
just linked in the past few days to a
political playbook piece called politico
politico buzz grows about bootage 2024.
buzz grows ooh buzz buzz buzz okay well
what's the buzz what's he pulling at
later in the piece they admit that
buddha judge's approval rating is only
38
so it's not you think presidential buzz
would be what like 60
70 80 percent no it's 38
he's only relatively buzzy his approval
is only relatively high because all of
the other people in the biden
administration are even lower
so the secretary of the treasury janet
yellen her approval rating is
33 percent
a merrick garland the attorney general
30
secretary of state anthony blinken oh
how's he doing after afghanistan 29
percent and those guys are relatively
high compared to the rest of the
administration secretary of defense
lloyd austin
26
white oh gosh white house chief of staff
ron claim
and energy secretary jennifer granholm
25
this is pathetic
the whole administration
on every single issue
is underwater
and so mayor pete
the
former mayor of south bend indiana whose
next job was transportation secretary
and then he immediately took two months
paternity leave
to
who to who knows to do what not sure
exactly what
what he would be doing during that time
what he wasn't doing was his job as
transportation secretary during a supply
chain crisis so very rarely does the
secretary of transportation matter it's
just not it's not one of the hottest
jobs in washington
once in a blue moon that job matters and
we just so happen to be living through
that blue moon because there is this
once in a lifetime supply chain crisis
going on and pete was absent on the job
because he was home chest feeding his
children
probably the presidential buzz
is
a mirage it's probably
a fever dream in the minds of desperate
liberal swamp creatures who are seeing
their chances at 2022 and 2024
disappearing before their very eyes
probably not gonna he's also
completely out of touch so even beyond
his dismal performance on the job and
his complete lack of political
experience before he got this job
he's also
absolutely unlikable and out of touch
joe bide or joe biden pete buda judge
was just asked on msnbc about what
americans can do who are struggling at
the pump don't forget gasp well you
don't forget because you fill up your
cars yourselves
gas prices are through the roof in
california they're up to seven dollars a
gallon
uh secretary budage
what do you what do you have to say to
americans who are struggling with the
difficult economy
and the high energy prices and it's
right around christmas time what do you
have to say and pete buddha judge says
buy an electric car
it contains incentives to make it more
affordable to buy an electric vehicle up
to a 12 500 discount in effect for
families thinking about getting an ev
families that once they own that
electric vehicle will never have to
worry about gas prices again
uh well what i would tell them is uh you
should just buy a tesla
just if you're having trouble filling up
your honda civic then just go and buy if
you want to buy a tesla model x that
used to be uh 106 thousand dollars but
now under the build back better act it's
only 91 000 so uh so we think this is
really going to help americans and then
you don't need to worry about gas
because electricity comes from magic so
it doesn't it's not
electricity you just
you just plug it into the electricity
tree and you never have to pay for it is
that how i don't think that's how that
works may repeat we'll just buy the
model s then then you'll only have to
pay fifty thousand dollars uh okay i
don't think that's gonna work buster i
don't who is this convincing
who like
what
does a politico reporter or a hill
reporter or any other beltway type from
the liberal establishment
what are they thinking
when they listen to this guy and they
say yes
there's there's the winning ticket for
middle america
they don't recognize the chasm
between
the institutions that they have spent a
lot of time in
and
reality
and part of this is because the elite
institutions once
played a huge role in shaping
the public opinion
and
they no longer do that to anywhere near
the same degree
the
debates in the yale political union
that's the debating club for
undergraduates at yale they used to be
reported in the newspapers the next day
the way it came now that that doesn't
happen okay
and part of this is because
all those people who would go to to
yale or harvard or princeton or whatever
they would
end up in the mainstream media not the
alternative media or some of us have
been banished but they would end up in
nbc abc
cbs the new york times the washington
post and
all of those
legacy media outlets had a lot more
influence and now they don't really
anymore and people are looking at
different sort of places
okay that common culture has been ripped
apart pete budage i think plays really
really well with a certain type of
liberal elite
the kind who went to harvard the kind
that worked at mckinsey consulting
the kind that still read the new york
times he he plays pretty well with them
but that the the times readership is
dwindling
okay the the cultural
prestige of places like harvard and yale
and princeton is dwindling
you used to think oh wow these are the
great elite institutions now you look
and you think oh yale that's the place
where that crazy shrieking girl screamed
at her professor and said this is not an
intellectual place it's a place of
comfort at home
oh yeah harvard this is now where all
these kooky students are protesting all
sorts of nonsense
oh yeah that i oh mackenzie what is that
doesn't play does not play so mayor pete
probably not going to play very well and
this is backed up by polling so there's
a new poll out from the hill and harris
x
showing that vice president kamala
harris and former first lady michelle
obama
are currently leading the pack for the
presidential nomination in 2024 if joe
biden is out
so you might you might expect kamalaris
even though she's so deeply unpopular
you think well she's the vice president
so she's just has better name
recognition and she's kind of considered
to be the next in line and michelle
obama that's kind of a surprising one
perhaps
the survey was of a little under a
thousand registered voters
harris led all the contenders contenders
with a 13 share of support 13. that's
all she got 13
obama michelle obama followed with 10
percent support poll had a 3.2 margin of
error so they're running neck and neck
other candidates received 5 or less that
includes bernie sanders elizabeth warren
cory booker
mayor pete
mike bloomberg oh my god andrew yang
okay
i don't think michelle obama wants to be
president i don't think she's doing the
kinds of things that you need to do if
you want to be president i don't think
she's shown really any interest in it
she's gotten to live in the white house
for eight years
she she really did not position herself
like for instance hillary did during the
bill administration during the clinton
one administration they position
themselves as two for one you're gonna
have co-presidents hillary clinton was
going to run the health care policy in
the 1990s
there were bumper stickers in the 90s
that said impeach clinton and her
husband
okay michelle wasn't doing that michelle
obama was focused on
getting kids to eat
apples and lunch right she was not doing
the sorts of things that would position
herself to run
and kamala harris is currently at 27
approval rating of 13
in this poll
the democratic party is in a lot of
trouble if joe biden doesn't run in
2024. now speaking of women's issues
you've got these two women topping the
poll
there is a woman with spina bifida which
is a debilitating condition
she has filed a lawsuit against her
mother's former doctor
seeking millions of dollars to cover her
health care costs
on the argument that she should never
have been
born
so evie toombes she's a 20 year old
equestrian show jumper from lincolnshire
england is suing general practitioner dr
philip mitchell
for wrongful conception this is
according to the telegraph
she says that the doctor quote failed to
advise her mother to take folic acid
supplements before getting pregnant and
she claims this resulted in her birth
defect she further claims according to
the post new york post
that her mother never would have had her
if her doctor had informed her that she
needed to take folic acid supplements to
minimize the chances of the defect
affecting her baby
so she is suing the doctor
for allowing her to exist
if the if the doctor had told the mother
to take this supplement then the mother
it's not even that the mother would have
aborted her exactly she's saying she
never would have conceived her in the
first place perhaps
and in any case the woman is saying i'm
alive
and that really offends me so you've got
to pay me millions of dollars this is
the logical conclusion i know it seems
very illogical and and it is in the
grand scheme of things but this is in a
narrow sense
the logical conclusion of a society that
views physical pleasure as the ultimate
end
and that's that's what we do and a lot
of cultures have viewed that
i viewed life that way throughout
society cultures that practice eugenics
tend to do that right if a baby is born
with a deformity kill that baby the
ancient spartans did that and we do that
today if a baby's conceived and has down
syndrome now doctors will tell you hey
we're going to screen for down syndrome
and then you can kill the baby if you
because you don't want a down syndrome
baby who would want a [ __ ] baby that
would be terrible right it'd be the
worst go kill your baby that's what they
say that's what they say in the doctor's
office
and
if you i remember because we you know we
were going through this and when my wife
was pregnant they said okay do you want
to test for
you know
abnormalities and we said absolutely not
i said well what do you mean you don't
want to i said why why would i test
because so that i can kill my kid no i'm
not going to kill my kid any either way
so no i don't think we want to do that
and they looked at the doctors look at
you like you're crazy
but societies that view physical
pleasure is the ultimate end of things
they don't think there's any higher end
in life they don't think there's any
higher justice any higher virtue than
just feeling good
they think that if you've got any kind
of suffering or suffering above a
certain threshold then it's better to to
be dead but this woman
obviously doesn't really believe that in
her heart of hearts
because if she really believed that it
were an injustice that she were alive
she would kill herself
and she's not killing herself she's
suing a doctor for millions of dollars
for being alive well if you think being
alive is such a terrible thing you can
end that right now you shouldn't that
would be a great sin but you can
she doesn't really believe it
she doesn't really believe that at all
i'm glad she doesn't believe that i'm
glad that at least at some really basic
level she recognizes the error of her
insane
view of the world but then take that to
its logical conclusion which is that
actually suffering isn't the worst thing
in the world actually physical pleasure
isn't the greatest thing in the world
actually maybe suffering can be
sanctifying actually maybe there's
something higher than physical pleasure
actually maybe
we're made in the image of god a god who
loves us a god who suffers for us and
maybe there there are higher things in
this world maybe we have a purpose here
and it's not just to feel good maybe
there's a higher morality than if you
feel good if it feels good do it
but a lot of people are confused these
days you want to talk about confused
women
demi lovato who is a hollywood celebrity
i don't even really remember what she's
known for but she has gone off the deep
end in recent years
she has just gone viral
again
for
spreading all kinds of kooky ideas about
aliens
and about the universe and about the
energy man you know and the vibrations
and people are making fun of her and
she's radically changed her appearance
in recent years and she is is indulging
in all of these strange
sexual ideologies and new agey type of
religious views
but what's even crazier
is that demi lovato
is no more nuts
than your average secular liberal today
demi lovato goes on some show i don't
know what joe was and
explains her encounters
with the supernatural
i decided to sing for them
and
they went off when i finished they i
never had
a standing ovation from ghosts i love it
but i'd like
you've made contact i have made contact
it's not been in like the et phone home
type of sense but
i have made contact by meditating and
looking up and seeing things in the sky
that weren't there when i started
meditating so now that you've made
contact with et's
maybe not this kind of contact yes yes
not yet but if there was an et
that hit every box of criteria that
would be like the most ideal partner
like would you date an e2 yes absolutely
i'm so tired of humans
i am so tired of humans and they're
human bull
i am so over it i like being an alien
yes
so a lot of people
watching this are saying don't do drugs
kids not even once this is your brain on
drugs not even i think that that's a
good argument
but i'll go further than that
i don't think that demi lovato is
especially nuts
certainly not by the standards of
hollywood but i don't even think she's
really especially nuts by the standards
of our
secular liberal culture
i think a lot of people believe the
stuff that she believes
i think if you she might be a little
more open about it and she's going on tv
shows about it but i think if you polled
your average
millennial girl
in
l.a or some liberal place
and you said hey do you believe in
in aliens
probably you'd hear yes i do believe in
aliens of course it's a big universe
we're not so special of course there
have to be aliens out there okay do you
believe in ghosts and spirits oh yeah
yeah man because i'm not really i'm not
religious you know not religion's bad
man but you know i'm spiritual you know
i'm really spiritual so i don't you know
i don't go to church but i go to yoga
you know and i meditate and i'm really
and i have crystals and i'm in touch
with in my horoscope you know i'm a
libra with an ascending scorpio and i
was born at the hour of the moon on if
and you know mercury's in retrograde so
what that means is that the universe man
is putting out vibes and you'll hear
this crap for hours if you go to a party
in l.a or
maybe a little less so in new york
people are slightly more grounded in new
york but austin i don't know san
francisco you go
anywhere
where the
secular liberal culture is
vibrant or
as vibrant as it can be
you will hear this kind of stuff
okay this
watered-down new age weirdness
and it reminds me that uh while the
secular liberals
believe that religious people christians
especially are superstitious
most superstitious people in the world
actually it reminds you
we are the least superstitious people in
the world traditionally religious people
tend to be
the least superstitious people in the
world because
contrary to the spiritual but not
religious people the people who take
religion seriously apply rigorous
systematic thinking to their religion
thomas aquinas was not spiritual but not
religious right thomas aquinas applies
rigorous logic to his religious views
and and discards certain views that were
popular at the time and goes further on
other views
this is true of all
serious theologians
there's a great there is a great meme i
saw going around of uh someone who was
uh in swimming in the ocean and had a
fishbowl on his head
and the fishbowl said religion in the
ocean said spirituality
and my my friend posted this meme and he
said
uh oh you mean that the the glass allows
you to see things more clearly actually
puts glass actually puts things into
perspective yeah i guess that is what
religion does
this stuff is much more pervasive and
and i think that uh
we
rather than just
laughing at the
most extravagant people who push this
this kind of craziness maybe we ought to
take a look at ourselves and examine our
own beliefs
and think hive
maybe my views aren't so different from
demi lovato's and maybe that's a problem
and maybe i should start thinking more
seriously about the universe man and my
place in it where do people learn this
stuff there's actually some good news
there's some good news here
undergraduate enrollment in america has
dropped eight percent in the last two
years
awesome great great stuff according to a
report from the national student
clearinghouse research center 7.8
percent fewer students are now
participating in undergraduate programs
with public two-year schools and private
for-profit four-year schools seeing the
most significant declines
this is really good stuff
i am not saying that no one should go to
college i know that some conservatives
say no one should go to college unless
you study engineering or whatever i
actually don't i don't think you should
study engineering in college i think you
should study literature and history and
philosophy and theology and the liberal
arts to help you make sense of your
freedom if you go to college at all and
there are very few institutions where
you can get a good education anyway
but i'm not saying no one should go to
college
i'm saying
you should keep the ends in mind
why are you going to college
for the conservatives who say we you
just need to study engineering in school
say why
why do you need to go to college to
learn engineering i actually don't think
you do you can go to trade school for
that if you want to just if you want to
learn business you don't need to go to
college
these are these are technical arts you
can learn them on the job it's probably
best
or you can learn them at a trade school
you can't really learn literature at
trade school you can do it on your own
but it helps to have a guide
it helps to have a teacher but what's
the what are you after
so many americans are blindly stumbling
into college and going into a quarter
million dollars of debt
to get a worthless degree where you
don't learn anything about a job you
don't learn anything about your freedom
you don't learn anything about your
civilization and the things you do learn
are bs
to quote tony soprano you finally read a
book and it's bs
so why would we do that got to keep the
ends and and you can apply this to the
broader society too what kind of society
do we want to have what is what is the
purpose of government of our communities
of our family of our place here what is
the purpose what do we want to see
happen in the end and how do we get
there i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daley wire
editor-in-chief
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode updates on the
waukesha attack the gelain maxwell trial
begins in new york and the senate
considers biden's build back better plan
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire